[Musik]
international Station
da kann man direkt bezahlen ja auch
schlau
jo Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut Leute
ich befinde mich hier gerade in London
und wir haben eine wilde wilde Fahrt vor
uns ich bin auf jeden Fall gestern hier
angekommen und habe was mit zwei
Freunden gemacht ja ich dachte mir ich
hätte es natürlich auch zurück fliegen
können aber man macht ja auch mal was
für die Umwelt und wir fahren heute mit
dem Zug ich habe mich hier auch nicht
lumpen lassen und einfach mal das
krasseste Gebot was geht das ist die
Business premier class also man kriegt
essen wir gehen jetzt gleich in der
Lounge und so ich habe richtig Bock und
wir fahren durch den Eurotunnel der Zug
nennt sich Eurostar und ist glaube ich
ziemlich bekannt aber so viele haben in
Deutschland noch nicht getestet das
sieht ja schon wieder echt nice aus und
guck mal da oben und ja labern war gar
nicht lange und gehen mal in die Sankt
pengress international Station
soweit ich weiß fährt von hier aus auch
nur der Eurostar und ich muss euch noch
mehr erzählen das habe ich mich noch
nicht getraut das kommt gleich noch es
wird ein bisschen wild bis das premier
klar okay ja hello okay
[Musik]
so Leute was geht ab ich weiß nicht ob
man es mir ansieht aber ich habe diese
Nacht nicht so viel Schlaf bekommen wir
waren gestern noch ein bisschen
unterwegs und ja gerade ist es let me
Check 8 Uhr 44 also wirklich noch nicht
so spät ich habe heute gebucht den
Eurostar nach Paris äh ich kann noch
nicht reden was ist los Mann
Konzentration ist so down ich sitze
gerade in der Lounge um Eurostar hier
gibt es jetzt schön Kaffee habe ich mir
auch verdient und Croissant oder sonst
was schauen wir uns sofort mal an und
dann fahre ich gleich mit dem Zug von
hier London durch so ein Tunnel der ist
ungefähr 75 m unter dem Ärmelkanal und
geht 50 km ja unterirdisch bis zum
französischen Festland hallo i am
testing your train to day so äh no
looking das ganze dauert auch mit
zweieinhalb Stunden also ich bin
wirklich mal gespannt wie es wird wenn
ich nicht so laut reden weil hier ist
eigentlich Ruhebereich ich habe 317 €
bezahlt fürs Ticket das coole ist man
bekommt an Bord aber auch so ein Sternen
Menü also von unserem Sternekoch
zubereitet irgendwie so ein bisschen
crazy stand da zumindest und ich hatte
einfach übelst Bock das auszuprobieren
also Leute ich wünsche euch ganz viel
Spaß diesem Video ach so vielleicht Job
ich das jetzt direkt dachte mir wenn ich
dann schon unterwegs bin mache ich auch
eine große Reise Ziel ist Istanbul ich
denke das werde ich in drei bis vier
Tagen schaffen ich habe ganz viele
verschiedene Züge gebucht auf diesem Weg
dorthin und ich denke es wird höchst
interessant ich habe keine Ahnung was
auf mich zukommt aber ich habe unfassbar
Bock ich hoffe ihr auch also lasst gerne
Abo da und wir starten jetzt mit einem
Kaffee hier gibt es auf jeden Fall
allerlei Auswahl an Kurs Songs
Schokobrötchen Brotaufstrich von A bis Z
Kaltgetränke Kaffee bis zum Abwinken
aber das sieht doch gut aus mmh lecker
lecker ach scheiße jetzt fällt mir
gerade auf ich habe mein Adapter
vergessen fürs Laden so damit kann man
doch gut starten es gibt einen Kaffee
ein Croissant und ein O-Saft das ganze
natürlich alles umsonst also nicht
umsonst aber ich kann mir hier nehmen
was ich will ist ja auch klar ne so
macht Reisen Spaß ich glaube hier geht
die Zeit ziemlich schnell rum ich
frühstücke jetzt erstmal in Ruhe und
dann werden wir ungefähr eine Stunde
aufgerufen
[Musik]
dann das ist jetzt der Zug der eine
Stunde eher fährt guck mal und dann
geht's gleich für mich auch los ich habe
Bock Leute
[Musik]
ich habe mir noch Musik abgeschaut da
hinten frisch zubereitet
okay
bye bye bye bye
so Leute Boarding ist ready ich muss
jetzt zu meinem Zug aber noch kurz auf
Toilette und dann heißt es ab nach Paris
ich freue mich schauen wir mal was wird
was wird ach so und ich dachte mir wenn
ich jetzt schon mal schnell auf Klo gehe
ach Männchen und Weibchen zusammen super
schön
ich könnte ja wenigstens mal kurz meine
Haare noch stylen ne das sieht ja
wirklich einfach nur bodenlos aus alles
schön sauber hier ja perfekt das coole
ist ich kann in Paris direkt in die
nächste Lounge gehen ich habe nämlich
erste Klasse gebucht TGB nach Zürich und
von Zürich geht's dann heute Abend mit
dem Nachtzug nach Wien Digger das wird
etwas
das hier ist übrigens mein Ticket sieht
25 und 14 Abteil ja
so und eigentlich sieht es hier aus wir
haben Flughafen hallo ich bin youtubers
hier entschuldigung ich musste da
unangenehm ich mag das gar nicht ne
[Musik]
so Leute hier haben wir ihn den Eurostar
der fährt nach Paris das ist meiner der
hier fährt glaube ich nach Amsterdam
oder so es gibt natürlich auch noch
andere Ziele okay Haare sind jetzt auch
nichts wegen besser aus alter ja ja die
beste premier class ist auf jeden Fall
ganz hinten das glaube ich gerne für die
die es interessiert die günstigste
Variante für mich wären so ungefähr 120
pounds gewesen und halt so die ganz
normale Standardklasse würde ich
normalerweise natürlich auch Reisen aber
wenn ich schon testen für den Youtube
Video dann natürlich hier wo haben wir
denn 14a
[Musik]
okay Leute Platz gefunden ja eigentlich
gar nicht mal so viel
pünktlich um 10 Uhr 22 Uhr jetzt auf
jeden Fall los das bin ich gar nicht
gewohnt weil ich war sonst immer nur in
Deutschland Zug der Tunnel müsste auch
eigentlich schon ziemlich schnell kommen
ich glaube man fährt über Brighton ihr
könnt das hier mal eingebildet sehen und
dann direkt unter Wasser gespannt das
London war schön hier
auch Deutsche Bahn und ich habe keine
Ahnung was ich zu essen bekomme weil ich
konnte das irgendwie nicht war auswählen
schauen wir mal machen so Leute ich habe
jetzt noch mal den Sitzplatz gewechselt
und jetzt habe ich hier etwas größeren
Tisch auf jeden Fall konnte man die
Karte jetzt auch online einstellen mit
diesem QR Code hier und da gibt's jetzt
einen freshes Menü auf jeden Fall also
das ist schon wild erstmal starde dann
haben wir irgendwie planen Steak glaube
gegangen die Salat natürlich unten
bisher es wird gut ich freue mich ja ich
würde es an Champagner an Bord das ist
so bei jedem mit inklusive der hier in
der Business Class heißt also irgendwie
so eine kleine Champagnerflasche muss
ich jetzt nicht unbedingt trinken aber
wenn ich jetzt schon hier bin
[Musik]
kann man machen um 10 Uhr morgens also
die Landschaft hier sind auf jeden Fall
schon echt schön ne toll so leute wir
befinden uns jetzt gerade hier zwischen
Ashford und Dover und hier müsste jetzt
gleich der Eurotunnel kommen ich bin
gespannt ja das sieht so aus genau das
ist schon die Bahn für die Autos ah nice
weil man kann den Bums ja auch mit dem
Auto passieren ich übrigens die ganze
Zeit Champagner ich bin gleich schon
voll Alter da steht noch mehr von dem
Zeug Leute wir sind auf jeden Fall jetzt
schon im Tunnel ich merke es noch ein
bisschen leichten Druck auf den Ohren
leider den Einstieg verpasst aber ich
hoffe vielleicht kannst Du rausfahren
der Eurotunnel ist auf jeden Fall 50 km
lang und verbindet jetzt Großbritannien
mit Frankreich schon krass also dass sie
mal irgendwann sowas gebaut haben finde
ich ne und ich wollte schon seit der 8
Klasse da haben wir das mal in der
Schule besprochen wollte ich mal diesen
Tunnel fahren
irgendwann werden alle Träume wahr es
kommt halt ganz auf die Uhrzeit an wann
man mit dem Eurostar reist dann gibt es
entweder Frühstück Brunch Mittagessen
oder eben auch Abendessen und bei mir
gab es gegen 11 Uhr am Montag zu
Vorspeise Rose asparagusmus war so
ähnlich wie Kräuterbutter einfach mit
einem Brötchen dazu als Hauptspeise
hatte ich dann Couscous mit Rinderfilet
oder das war so Gulasch ähnlich war aber
wirklich sehr sehr lecker es gab auch
eine Salat Alternative und als Nachtisch
hatte ich dann Pistazie mit so Mousse
und ja ich weiß gar nicht genau was das
war aber es war wirklich super geil ja
Leute wirklich Geistes kann gut hätte
ich nicht gedacht ist wirklich wie in
einem guten Restaurant das also kann man
gar nicht mit dem Flugzeug essen oder so
vergleichen gerade Business Class
Flugzeug Essen vielleicht aber das Bifi
ist schon sehr sehr wild das nicht ganz
so meins aber das hier brutal jetzt sind
wir schon in Frankreich Alter das Ding
so schnell ne wir sind zwischenzeitlich
über 320 km/h gefahren also das schon
sehr flott ich bin noch nie so entspannt
gereist und
aber tut mir leid dass ich nicht so laut
reden kann wegen hier sind noch andere
die wollen ihre Ruhe haben ich bin nicht
stören
[Musik]
ich bin hier gerade auf der Toilette so
sieht's aus alles eigentlich ähnlich wie
in einem in der Regionalbahn auf
Behindertentoiletten oder so da eine
Euro waren kennt ihr die Eurobahn das
ist eigentlich genauso aus also jetzt
nichts besonderes aber habe ich auch
nicht erwartet ey das Essen das war 1A
mit Sternchen muss ich wirklich sagen
meine Friese ist aber alles andere als
1A mit Sternchen
ich habe gerade auf jeden Fall schon ein
Eiffelturm gesehen also noch 10 Minuten
dann sind wir da dort ging echt flott
muss ich sagen also London Paris 2
Stunden 20 Geisteskranke bye bye so
Leute angekommen Paris nice
so Leute ich bin da mega nice wir haben
nur ein Problem mein nächster Zug der
fährt vom Paris de Lyon oder so und das
ist 6 km weg da muss ich jetzt irgendwie
hinkommen irgendwie junge was ich heute
alles an einem Tag erlebe ne also doch
schön aus hier und wie könnte man da
jetzt einfacher hinkommen als mit diesem
coolen Fahrrad let's go ich hoffe du
hast noch Akku okay Leute es ist ein
bisschen windig heute hier in Paris
deswegen habe ich mal meinen
anstrengenden rausgeholt ich wollte
nämlich noch entspannt eine Bewertung
abgeben für den Zug das mache ich jetzt
immer hinter mir ist übrigens irgend so
ein ähm ja was ist das eigentlich keine
Ahnung Siegessäule das ist woanders
eigentlich wollte ich zum Eiffelturm
laufen nur der ist ein bisschen weit weg
das werden über 6 km und das schaffen
jetzt nicht ich bin jetzt auf jeden Fall
hier unten an der Sand habe ich in
meinem Französisch noch nicht gelernt
dass es sich Sam wie ist nochmal die aus
dem französischbuch also schönes Paris
ja allemal ne das kann man ja nicht
anders sagen so jetzt habe ich was
gefunden Kamera hier drauf stellen auf
die Mülltonne ich hoffe ihr könnt mich
alle gut sehen also ich habe mich jetzt
dazu entschieden die Züge auch immer zu
bewerten wir haben fünf verschiedene
Kategorien und wir starten jetzt einfach
mal mit dem Eurostar und zwar gibt es
einmal die Kategorie Komfort Essen
Service
naturerlebnisfaktor und Preis-Leistung
also fünf verschiedene ich kann immer 1
bis 5 Sterne geben und am Ende haben wir
dann eine Gesamtwertung und mal gucken
welcher Zug den ich testen werde so am
besten abschneidet also Komfort muss man
ganz klar sagen wann safe 5 von 5 Sterne
einfach bombastisch so ich habe mich da
echt wohl gefühlt konnte übelst chillen
und war alles perfekt essen muss ich
auch sagen für den Zug 55 Sterne also
egal ich wusste gar nicht dass es
überhaupt irgendwo auf der Welt Einzug
gibt wo das Essen so krank ist also es
war wie in einem vernünftig guten
Restaurant
Alemannia Coco nee warte mal das war
Spanisch dann haben wir als nächstes
Service und auch da muss ich sagen 555
Sterne alles top zufrieden super die
haben mich zehnmal gefragt ob ich noch
Champagner haben will ich ich dann schon
fast besoffen
sorry also bis jetzt haben wir 15 von 15
möglichen Sternen das tut mir auch leid
aber ich kann ja nichts anderes machen
weil dem tollen Erlebnis was ich da
gerade hatte als nächstes Kategorie
Natur Schrägstrich Erlebnisfaktor kann
man verstehen oder was ich damit meine
einfach wo fährt man lang ist das
abenteuerlich oder eventuell auch nicht
hier würde ich drei von fünf Sterne
geben man hat halt eigentlich nur Tunnel
gesehen und die französische Landschaft
war top da ist auf jeden Fall noch
Potential nach oben und preis leistung
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen fand ich
auch absolut okay 317 € habe ich bezahlt
würde ich vier von fünf Sterne geben ist
natürlich schon teuer aber für die
Leistung die man bekommt eigentlich auf
jeden Fall passabel und okay landen wir
am Ende bei 22 von 25 möglichen Stern ja
aber übelst da ist also Eurostar kann
ich jedem empfehlen geil Erfahrung für
mich geht's jetzt zum nächsten Bahnhof
und dann geht's weiter nach Zürich ich
glaube das Video beende ich jetzt hier
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen abonniert
super gerne den Kanal für die
Weiterreise für mich geht's ja bis nach
Istanbul mal gucken wenn ich da ankomme
ich habe Bock Leute Daumen nach oben
würde ich mich auch freuen jetzt noch
ein Baguette essen und dann ab nach
Zürich